am domplatz in thüringen ist heute
wahlsonntag 1,7 millionen menschen sind
aufgerufen ihren neuen landtag zu wählen
und hier im parlamentsgebäude in erfurt
haben auch wir unser wahlstudio
aufgebaut für einen wahlabend der
wirklich spannend werden dürfte
ja und dazu begrüßen wir sie sehr
herzlich vor fünf jahren endete die wahl
hier in thüringen mit einer faustdicken
überraschung die cdu bliebe zwar
stärkste kraft musste aber nach
jahrzehnten ihre macht abgeben
ein linker ministerpräsident bodo
ramelow übernahmen und der wille es
matthias fornoff jetzt mit seiner rot
rot grünen regierung noch mal wissen ja
das schreckgespenst eines linken
regierungschefs das hat sich schnell
verflüchtigt auch weil bodo ramelow fast
schon entkoppelt von seiner partei eher
präsidial regiert hat und sich dabei
bemüht hat bürgernah zu wirken
wohl auch deshalb könnte die linke
erstmals überhaupt in einem bundesland
stärkste partei werden
die afg kann wohl ihr ergebnis
verdoppeln
mit einem landesverband hier in
thüringen der äußerst weit rechts steht
cdu und spd müssen erneut mit schweren
einbußen rechnen
wenn die mitte der abbröckelt und die
ränder wachsen dann wird es immer
schwieriger mehrheiten zu organisieren
die politisch machbar sind mit tina und
das wird wohl das thema dieses abends
mindestens mal davon können wir ausgehen
was geht was geht nicht das dürfte die
spannende frage heute abend sein wir
haben knapp 20 minuten eine gute
viertelstunde bis zur prognose der
forschungsgruppe wahlen und schauen
zunächst mal genauer auf die politische
ausgangslage genau genommen tut dass
matthias kubitz für uns
wie wunderbar ist thüringen von der
wartburg ganz im westen bis ins fast
schon sächsische altenburg von
barbarossas barth am kyffhäuser bis
sonneberg der fränkischen spielzeugstadt
[Applaus]
thüringen auferstanden aus ruinen
seit der wende ging es ziemlich bergauf
zumindest in den zentren erfurt weimar
jena lebenswert modernen wirtschaft
stark auf dem land und an den rändern
aber viel frust wegzug überalterung die
politische stimmung im freistaat so
kontrastreich wie die lebenswelten soll
bodo ramelow weiter regieren oder muss
ein wechsel her
ich hoffe dass das noch mal schafft und
dass die fce 0 chance hat ich denke mal
geschafft dass herr ob das ding also ich
glaube rot rot grün wird zu engen die
politische stimmung denn der cfd
eindeutig also in den leuten models
überall haben alle die schnauze voll die
stimmung ist sehr gespalten
lange schon unlösbar die bildungsmisere
frustrierend viele freistunden weil akut
lehrer fehlen außerdem zu wenig kitas in
den wachsenden städten
wir hatten glück bei uns im ersten kind
und sind auf der warteliste
nachgerutscht
die stunden fallen aus die kinder werden
eingeschickt was da an stunden wegfällt
das ist wirklich enorm und da musste ich
definitiv auch was tun und auch nicht
mehr zu sagen wie quereinsteigern ist
das ganze auch nicht gemacht
thüringen raus geht es rasend schnell
mit 300 sachen nach münchen oder berlin
in vielen orten um die ecke aber
anschluss abgebaut
den thüringern fehlen busse und bahnen
ich komme gerade aus einer ortschaft wo
auch die bahnlinie stillgelegt worden
ist man fühlt sich sehr aufs auto
angewiesen
sehr stark ganz deutschland ist gespannt
wie die thüringer 30 jahre nach der
wende wählen
doch so richtig lassen sie sich noch
nicht in die karten schauen ein paar
minuten noch dann ist die richtung
vielleicht klarer ja so es ist dann wohl
andreas postel ist der leiter des
zdf-studios hier in thüringen hat den
wahlkampf natürlich intensiv beobachtet
und erinnert sich natürlich auch noch
vor fünf jahren gab es ja noch richtige
demonstrationen gegen einen linken
ministerpräsidenten von der linken der
sed nachfolgepartei das
hat sich dann aber sehr schnell gegeben
oder ja also es hat vor fünf jahren kaum
jemand damit gerechnet dass bodo ramelow
tatsächlich diese rot rot grüne
regierung fünf jahre lang durchhalten
wird mit einer stimme mehrheit hat der
regiert und das hat wahrscheinlich alle
partner auch diszipliniert deswegen man
wollte den erfolg und er hat es jetzt
auch geschafft fünf jahre zu regieren
und auf der anderen seite hatte er
günstige voraussetzungen eine
schönwetter koalition sozusagen weil die
steuereinnahmen sprudelten und deren
schuldenabbau einleiten konnte mehr
lehrer einstellen konnte mehr polizei
also insgesamt glaube ich eine bilanz
die auch die meisten thüringer überzeugt
der wahlkampf das haben wir beobachtet
sie besonders war ungeheuer polarisiert
aggressiv es gab morddrohungen hier
unter anderem gegen den cdu
spitzenkandidaten mohring wie haben sie
das erlebt ja also es gab morddrohungen
gegen mohring den spitzenkandidaten der
cdu und auch gegen den spitzenkandidaten
der grünen
es gab zerrissene wahlplakate es gab
beschmutzte mit farbbeuteln versehrte
wahlkampfbüros also insgesamt eine
ziemlich aufgeladene stimmung mit schuld
daran sicherlich auch der starke afd
protagonisten höcke es gab keine
wahlkampfveranstaltung wo nicht auch
starke die gegendemonstrationen
stattgefunden haben und diese
polarisierung die hat dem amtsinhaber
offensichtlich auch ein bisschen genutzt
sowie in sachsen oder brandenburg auch
scheint bodo ramelow davon zu
profitieren
aber am ende muss er natürlich auch eine
regierung bilden können und das steht
jetzt noch nicht fest vielen dank für
den moment bis später andreas postel ja
wir haben noch gut zehn minuten bis zur
prognose da wollen wir kurz zu den
parteien natürlich schauen unsere
reporterinnen und reporter sind heute
abend überall unterwegs um die stimmung
auszuloten und wir beginnen mal bei den
drei kleineren parteien dazu zählt in
der tat inzwischen auch die spd die hier
mit weiteren verlusten rechnen muss laut
der von umfragen dieser mit rücker ist
dort ja wie es die erwartung lisa
ja hier bei der spd trifft man sich
heute im café du dich in der engelsburg
eine recht entspannte location mitten in
der erfurter altstadt die stimmung
allerdings die ist hier doch eher
angespannt man fürchtet erneute verluste
ja und diejenigen mit denen ich bereits
sprechen konnte die haben mir gesagt
dass man zumindest hofft weiter regieren
zu können aber man weiß natürlich dass
es für eine fortsetzung der gewünschten
rot-rot-grünen koalition durchaus knapp
werden könnte also die anspannung die
liegt ja förmlich in der luft und alle
wollen jetzt natürlich wissen was die 18
uhr prognose in wenigen minuten sagt und
damit zurück ins wahlstudio zu bettina
schausten danke lisa und weiter zu den
grünen die auf rückenwind aus berlin und
aus dem klimathema hoffen schipanski ist
bei den grünen
und die frage ist natürlich ob überhaupt
rückenwind in thüringen ankommt in
brandenburg und sachsen zuletzt haben
wir gesehen hat das ja nur mäßig
geklappt die grünen haben sich ein altes
kulturcafé ausgesucht wo man feiern will
mit einer über 100 jahre alten
geschichte mit vielen aufs und ups und
in gewisser weise gilt das auch für die
grünen man hat zwar nicht diese lange
geschichte aber wenn man schaut seit dem
mauerfall gab es sechs wahlen und bei
diesen sechs wahlen war man drei mal
drin im landtag und drei mal draußen
insofern ist die erwartungshaltung sagen
wir durchaus gedämpft man hat ein ziel
knapp zweistellig das wäre wohl schon
ein erfolg so sagt man und das zweite
große ziel ist es natürlich dass man
weiter regieren möchte und da stehen die
zeichen nicht unbedingt schlecht ob es
rot grün wird es ja eine sache aber die
grünen werden so zumindest ob man hier
auf jeden fall für eine neue
regierungsbildung gebraucht
dank ralf ja wir gehen noch weiter zur
fdp die vor fünf jahren aus dem landtag
heraus gefallen ist und jetzt den
wiedereinzug schaffen will in der
christen ist dort wie groß ist die
zuversicht dass das klappt
vorsichtig optimistisch so würde ich die
stimmung hier bei den liberalen in
erfurt beschreiben der landeschef thomas
kemmerich der will nach fünf jahren
pause zurück in den landtag sprach von
sieben bis acht prozent im wahlkampf
letzten umfragen sagen die partei aber
er so bei 5 prozent
es könnte also sehr sehr knapp werden
und auch sehr spannend denn die fdp ist
hier mit einer art versprechen
angetreten war die fdp wählt der kann
eine neuauflage von rot rot grün
verhindern und ganz unwahrscheinlich ist
das nicht denn sollte das dfb
tatsächlich in den landtag schaffen
dann könnte es irgend werden für das
bündnis von bodo ramelow in thüringen
das ist der plan soll es anders werden
als in brandenburg und sachsen und
sollte dieser plan aufgehen dann wäre
das für die liberalen nicht nur hier in
thüringen eine kleine sensation
dankeschön linda ja und man sieht schon
ein dreierbündnis ohne fdp ein vierer
bündnis mit fdp oder gar nichts geht und
es kommt zu einer minderheitsregierung
all das ist ja denkbar und wir werden
später sehen wie es kommt gut auf jeden
fall dass professor karl rudolf korte
heute dabei ist
da brauchen wir dann eine ordnende hand
sozusagen aber besser konnte was ist das
besondere wirklich an dieser
ausgangslage wo er jetzt schon im
vorhinein in thüringen gesprochen wird
darüber dass vielleicht gar nichts geht
ja es wird die weimarer verhältnisse in
stabile regierungsbildung und stimmungs
verfinsterung durch polarisierung auf
der straße wenn die drei größeren
parteien hier die afg die linke und die
cdu nicht zusammen arbeiten wollen ist
unklar wie man eine regierung bild kann
mir braucht manager der instabilität
vielleicht auch mut vielleicht labilität
zu wagen und schöpferisch experimentell
gibt es modelle in anderen bundesländern
oder europaweit wie man vielleicht eine
mehrheit finden könnte jedenfalls ist es
gefährlich bei solchen verhältnissen
schon im vorhinein dinge auszuschließen
frist ja man sollte nicht zuviel
ausschließen aber der wähler möchte
natürlich wissen was mit der stimme
passiert ist keine lotterie sofern muss
man auch wahrhaftig bleiben um die
wähler nicht zu täuschen
danke für den moment professor karte wir
sehen uns später wieder und bevor wir
gleich nach der stimmung bei den
parteien an der spitze fragen wirft
matthias kubitz ahl noch mal einen
genaueren blick auf die wahlkämpfer
selbst die spitzenkandidaten
wer wandert mit wem
vor fünf jahren hatte rot rot grün genug
kraft um zusammen zu gehen wenn jetzt
einer zuseher schwächelt ist der linke
weg versperrt bodo ramelow kämpft ums
weiterregieren als erster linker
landesvater wurde er anfangs skeptisch
beäugt dem einstigen gewerkschafter aus
dem westen gelingt jedoch das ruhige
regieren christ sozialist
ministerpräsident für alle ramelow
beherrscht seine rollen jetzt macht er
die linke wohl erstmals zur stärksten
kraft doch was nützt das wenn die
partner nicht punkten
deswegen habe ich auch ausdrücklich
dafür darüber nachzudenken spd zu wählen
bündnis 90 die grünen zu wählen und oder
die linke zu wenig wärme also nicht nur
für meine eigene partei oder nicht nur
für mich persönlich sondern ich werbe
für dieses politische konzepte thüringen
für die cdu zurück erobern will mike
mohring schwierig aber nicht
ausgeschlossen wenn es für rot rot grün
nicht reicht früher selbstbewusst mit
breiter basis bleibt der union heute
bloß ein schmaler pfad zwischen den
fronten fdp und linkspartei sind für
mohring keine optionen abgrenzung von
links abgrenzung von rechts und die
mitte mobilisieren da sind die thüringer
zu hause und ich glaube die wollen auch
in der mitte und auch in der regierung
haben und nicht vom rand aus bestimmt
wird
die afg wohl doppelt so stark wie vor
fünf jahren
deren höcke bejubelt off plätzen sein
rechter flügel als verdachtsfall
beobachtet vom verfassungsschutz
der provokateur der auch wieder man kann
wird sein ziel wohl verfehlen wir wollen
stärkste kraft werden wir wollen auch in
regierungsverantwortung das haben wir
immer gesagt und das ist das ziel die
spd ohne rückenwind aus berlin in
thüringen wohl erstmals einstellig
trotzdem sie weiterregieren wir wollen
in der nächsten regierung rot rot grün
die stabilisierende die ausgleichende
kraft sein mit starken ministerien
auch für die grünen bleibt thüringen
schwieriges terrain
trotz starkem bundestrend land will sie
wohl unter zehn prozent
wenn es möglich ist wollen wir gerne
diese rot rot grüne koalition in der wir
jetzt arbeiten fortsetzen ganz klar mit
dieser grünen handschrift wie wir sie
bislang haben wenn die fdp in den
landtag schafft ist eine rot-rot-grüne
mehrheit unwahrscheinlich wo also geht's
lang in thüringen wer regiert das land
weiter wie gehabt oder alles offen
ich habe bei den wahlen in brandenburg
und sachsen da haben wir zuletzt gesehen
dass am ende die partei des jeweiligen
ministerpräsidenten noch mal ordentlich
zulegen konnte
matthias fornoff das nennt man dann
amtsbonus ja und auf diesen amtsbonus
kann auch bodo ramelow mit fug und recht
setzen das sehen wir hier in der ersten
grafik denn fast drei viertel der
thüringer sagen er macht seine arbeit
gut und das zieht sich quer durch alle
parteianhänger schafften nur die
anhänger der afd stimmen dem
mehrheitlich nicht zu die stärke des
ministerpräsidenten das ist auch eine
wichtige erklärung dafür dass wir hier
keine erkennbare wechselstimmung haben
wir schauen jetzt nochmal auf die
bewertung der parteien hier in thüringen
durch die wählerinnen und wähler
positive werte sehen wir hier für die
cdu und für die linke auch für die spd
und die fdp die grünen knapp im minus
bewertet und äußerst negative werte für
die afg da sehen wir jetzt in zahlen
die polarisierung von der vorhin stand
die rede war
wie sich das alles im ergebnis sortiert
und welche mehrheiten möglich sind das
wird der abend zeigen
das ist in der tat war so ist also die
ausgangslage für die parteien und wir
setzen unseren rundlauf jetzt auch ford
und schauen zu unseren reportern bei der
linken bei cdu und fdp cordes beobachtet
die afg heute abend die hier ja wir
haben es gesehen mit burn herantritt dem
vertreter des extrem rechten völkisch
nationalen flügel und mit deutlichen
zugewinnen rechnen kann via martin fand
ich so ein bisschen trotz röcke oder
wegen höcke
der berliner dieser frage werden wir
nachgehen hier die hälfte frei hat heute
im restaurant hauptwerk das ist ein
traditionsreiches altes und bürger nicht
so bürger nicht dass wir bisher die cdu
immer ihre wahlkarte veranstaltung und
hsdpa eine bürgerliche partei seien aber
da ist die unterstützten kandidaten
höcke die reizfigur die umstrittene
reizfigur der urteil schlechthin und die
frage wird man also sein schafft es
dieser jahren höcke ähnlich wie zuletzt
die fdp nur und den sachsen wo ebenfalls
25 prozent der wählerstimmen hinter sich
zu versammeln oder bleibt er eben dann
doch hinter den ergebnissen zurück weil
er möglicherweise ein bürgerliches
publikum versteckt diese beobachtung
gründer studio dankeschön party niemals
den eindruck da wird jetzt schon
gefeiert vorab bei der cdu ist heute
abend wohl schmiese unser reporter wolf
beim letzten mal war die cdu doch
immerhin noch stärkste kraft in
thüringen wenn es auch eben für die
regierungsbildung nicht reichte
jetzt droht auch der verlust des
spitzenplatzes was rechnet man sich da
noch aus
also man feiert hier direkt neben dem
dom in einem palais was man angemietet
hat und eine cdu wahlkämpferin sagte vor
hinzu mir lieber gott lass noch ein
wunder geschehen das ist ein bisschen
hier die stimmung dass man wirklich
hofft man könnte mit hilfe aller
parteien außer eben der linken und der
afd
doch noch den ministerpräsidenten mike
mohring stellen und das wäre sozusagen
die als option nur die nächste option
wäre dass man hinter die afg rutscht und
sozusagen noch nicht mal die
oppositionsführerschaft hätte und ein
bisschen habe ich den eindruck die
gedrückte stimmung die überwiegt schon
aber das werden wir gleich sehen ob die
hier recht haben mit ihrer stimmung dank
wolfs zuletzt der blick zur linkspartei
zu christina von ungern-sternberg ja da
bahnt sich ja dann durchaus ein
historischer erfolg für die linke an
aber es könnte eben dennoch für rot rot
grün nicht mehr erreichen dies die
stimmung
die stimmung lässt sich kaum wenn ich
das schreibe wahrscheinlich kaufen
verstehen weil die stimmung so gut ist
das ist wahrscheinlich die einzige
gemeinsamkeit die linkspartei und die
haben wir heute haben dass die
partystimmung jetzt schon vor wichtig zu
schauen ist die bundeswehr in dieser
branche location dem man sich ausgewählt
hat in so vielen leuten und der auch
schon viele leute sind in der letzten
stunde haben wir hier sehr viel musik
gehört nicht gehört ich nur so aus er
hat ein lied geschrieben das heißt
keinen bock zu geben
das hat die stimmung der politischen
linken heute abend kann um zusammen
dankeschön
sina von ungern sternberg und da können
wir doch eine minute nein eine minute 20
vor der prognose noch daran anknüpfen
professor karte kein bock zu gehen hieß
es da gerade interessant ist ja wirklich
in thüringen
wenn es für keine der jetzt avisierten
mehrheiten reichen würde in der tat
könnte bodo ramelow als
geschäftsführender ministerpräsident
erstmal unbegrenzt eigentlich im amt
bleiben ja weil das gegensatz zu den
anderen waren die wir vor ein paar
wochen erlebt haben keine befristung
gibt wann ein ministerpräsident zu
wählen ist und wenn er nicht wählbar ist
müsste ein landtag neu gewählt wird das
gibt es hier nicht geschäfts führen kann
man regieren
so wie das in hessen auch schon
ministerpräsidenten gemacht haben auch
mehrere jahre sogar das ist also denkbar
und noch eine besonderheit er könnte
sich aber auch als bist als
ministerpräsident ohne mehrheit zur wahl
stellen und hätte sogar gewisse chancen
ja denn als geschäftsführender
ministerpräsident wird einem angeraten
keine gesetz zu erlassen wurde ein
haushalt für die nächsten jahre bereits
hat aber wenn der gesetzgeber tätig
werden will sollte er sich als
ministerpräsident will im dritten
wahlgang kann er mit einfacher mehrheit
gewählt werden und sich einen partner
suchen zwei oder drei zum stützen zu
tolerieren es gibt so viele modelle so
dankeschön da gucken wir jetzt schon
drauf und erst mal sind wir jetzt
gespannt auf die prognose der
forschungsgruppe wahlen
wie kommt jetzt
für die cdu in thüringen 22 prozent mit
sehr deutlichen verlusten linke 30
prozent leichte gewinne spd 8 prozent
mit verlusten afd 23 prozent das sind
sehr starke gewinne grüne 5,5 ähnlich
wie vor fünf jahren fdp 5,5 mit gewinn
und wohl wieder im landtag die anderen
zusammen 6 prozent ja und jetzt ist die
große frage was bedeutet das für
mehrheiten wir hören jetzt alles zu
sitzverteilung 'nen und möglichen
koalition von matthias fonger waren
jetzt erst mal aus prozent besitze und
schauen auf die sitzverteilung erfordern
landtag nach dieser prognose 88 sitze
wenn es keine überhangmandate gibt 45
sitze sind die absolute mehrheit da
sehen wir die linke mit 28 die spd mit
sieben cdu mit 21 die afg mit 22 sitzen
und die fdp mit fünf sitzen
was heißt das fürs regieren hier für
welche koalition könnte es reichen wir
sehen hier diese senkrechte linie die
muss man erreichen 45 sitzt oder liegt
die absolute mehrheit die im moment
regierende koalition linke spd und grüne
verfehlt das um fünf sitze recht
deutlich cdu spd und grüne erst recht
das sind nur 33 sitze wenn sie die fdp
noch mit ins boot nehmen sind 38 sitze
auch das reicht nicht ein ungewöhnliches
bündnis aus linke spd grüne und fdp
dieses viererbündnis würde es gerade so
schaffen
und jetzt schauen wir doch auf die
wahlbeteiligung die es hier in thüringen
wie schon in sachsen und brandenburg
gestiegen von 52,7 prozent vor fünf
jahren auf jetzt 66 prozent dankeschön
matthias fonger von jetzt haben wir hier
schon einen ersten gast ich begrüße
dietmar bartsch den bundes den
fraktionsvorsitzenden im deutschen
bundestag der linken arbeit so das ist
jetzt erst mal ein historisches ergebnis
tatsächlich für die linke und wir gucken
jetzt gemeinsam mal kurz wie das bei
ihrer partei hier in thüringen erlebt
worden ist so
da sehen war christina von ungarn stand
barth da wird es wird immer noch
gejubelt ganz genau das macht für uns
ein bisschen schwierig und gerade
während ich spreche jetzt hat der
kipping die bundesvorsitzende auf der
bühne
um hier den wahlkämpfer ihr großes lob
auszusprechen
man will zeigen ein linker
ministerpräsident ist kein ausrutscher
sondern eine sache an die man sich
gewöhnen kann und soll wie man das jetzt
hier anstellen will das kann man in dem
moment mechaniker haben erstmal mit hier
gefeiert
castro über das erste mal hier geleistet
hat um alles andere wird der abend das
dankeschön christina herbert so viel
jubel hatten sie auch lange nicht aber
ist das jetzt wirklich so ein erfolg für
die linke oder nicht vor allem ein
persönlicher erfolg für bodo ramelow
nein das ist ein sensationelles ergebnis
bei dieser gestiegenen wahlbeteiligung
noch einmal zuzulegen das erste mal in
einem bundesland stärkste partei zu sein
das ist das verdienst von bodo ramelow
natürlich auch das verdienst der
thüringer linken ich sage es ein
historischer ein sensationeller sieg und
das lohnt sich heute zu feiern
gleichzeitig muss man dennoch fragen was
macht man jetzt daraus für rot rot grün
reicht es nicht das war das eigentliche
ziel von bodo ramelow was nun mehr wir
werden schauen wie sich die zahlen
entwickeln das ist jetzt wirklich noch
zu früh er ist ein klarer
regierungsauftrag für bodo ramelow
es gibt überhaupt keine andere
möglichkeiten als ministerpräsidenten
und wir werden schauen wie sich das hier
in thüringen heute abend mit dem
wahlergebnis und dann noch mit den
gesprächen entwickelt erst mal sind wir
als linke glücklich so ein ergebnis das
haben wir uns kaum träumen lassen wenn
ich fünf jahre zurückdenke was da an
erfolg jetzt stande gekommen ist bin ich
ein bisschen stolz und gleichwohl ist es
so dass die afg sehr stark geworden ist
in thüringen wenn man hier mal jetzt an
die verantwortung auch der regierung auf
die verantwortung schaut ist da auch zu
viel raum gelassen worden dass hier die
afg so stark werden könnte man erstmal
will ich feststellen dass die arch die
lange nicht so stark ist wie in sachsen
und auch nicht wie in brandenburg aber
das ist ein problem
ein problem das wir alle haben wir
müssen dort nicht nur nachdenken sondern
konsequent handeln
da sind wir gefordert nicht nur die
politischen parteien ich brauche die afg
nicht sie ist auch nicht gut für
thüringen wir müssen das zur kenntnis
nehmen sie ist viel zu stark aber heute
heute ist erstmal festzustellen dass das
was die wollten 25 prozent stark
heute ist alles nicht eingetreten sieger
dieses wahlabends heißt die linke
thüringen und bodo ramelow und sollte
dann bodo ramelow auch in anklam er
könnte ja geschäftsführend bleiben sind
dass stabile verhältnisse wenn man sagt
jetzt geschäftsführend
minderheitsregierung ist das etwas was
man anstreben also man muss erstmal das
wahlergebnis abwarten ich erinnere mich
vor fünf jahren wurde auch gesagt wie
instabil dass sein wird mit rot-rot-grün
es war eine regierung die erfolgreich
gehandelt hat und ich gehe davon aus
dass bodo ramelow eine stabile regierung
bilden wird und das land weiter
erfolgreich führen wird sagt dietmar
bartsch der fraktionsvorsitzenden im
deutschen bundestag der linke schön dank
dass sie so schnell bei uns waren und
wir wollen natürlich jetzt dieses
ergebnis auch für die anderen parteien
vertiefen und ich frag jetzt mal nach
beschließe der ja bei der cdu hier ist
deutliche verluste zweistellige verluste
für die cdu das hatte sich der
spitzenkandidat mike mohring anders
vorgestellt wo ich berichte mal von der
stimmung
bettina ich habe noch nie einen bahn
abend erlebt der so still aufgenommen
wurde wirklich kein mucks alle die die
vorher sozusagen noch entschlossen waren
man wolle doch trotzig applaudieren und
mal gucken haben dann plötzlich
geschwiegen die gesichter gingen runter
es war nichts zu hören ich heute nur
dass einer sagte ach du und das wort
nenne ich jetzt nicht also so etwas
frustriertes hat man selten gesehen die
an diesem abend hier in thüringen direkt
neben dem erfurter dom
ja und über die ursachen wird jetzt
sicherlich intensiv diskutiert werden
auch wir können jetzt schon eine stimme
hören aus der cdu ich bin verbunden mit
reiner haselhoff der ministerpräsident
von sachsen anhalt und der ist ja
gleichzeitig mitglied im bundesvorstand
auch der cdu haseloff danke dass sie
bereit stehen ein drittel der stimmen
sozusagen ist verloren gegangen das ist
ein miserabler abend für die cdu wie
erklären sie sich das das ist ein
bitterer abend für uns aber auch ein
bitterer abend für die demokratische
mittel dann zum ersten mal hat es bei
der landtagswahl in deutschland keine
mehrheit für die parteien in der mitte
gegeben
in fünf jahren der letzten
legislaturperiode in thüringen sind die
ränder gestärkt hervorgegangen und sind
so stark dass in der mitte keine
regierung bild bar ist das ist schon
etwas besonderes und zeigt eigentlich
wie sehr gespalten und auch polarisiert
die gesellschaft dort ist und was auch
für die zukunft gemacht werden muss
damit die demokratische mitte wieder
auch eine eigene möglichkeit hat eine
regierung zu bilden
und dennoch ist sind diese verluste
möglicherweise auch hausgemachte hatte
mike mohring da die richtige strategie
gefahren er hat sich schaaf zur afg
abgegrenzt das hat offenkundig nicht
gereicht war es richtig sich auch zur
linken abzugrenzen weil das die richtige
strategie hat einen hervorragenden
wahlkampf geführt hat sich völlig mit
seiner mannschaft eingesetzt man weiß ja
auch welche voraussetzungen ja am anfang
hatte auch gesundheitlich und hat das
toll gemacht auf der anderen seite muss
man klar sagen es gibt einen amtsbonus
des amtsinhabers und die abgrenzung das
ist ja gefragt wurden von ihnen ist
richtig es muss möglich sein in
deutschland in der mitte eine mehrheit
zu finden und wenn das nicht passiert
dann stehen wir auf einem
demokratiepolitischen problemen und
darüber müssen wir reden denn wir sind
nicht im jahr 2015 16
sondern wir haben es ja auch mit einer
starken fdp zu tun die insgesamt
deutschlandweit auch völlig anders
angegangen werden muss auch mit rezepten
und konzepten geht dazu führen dass die
politischen ränder marginalisiert werden
und gehörte zu einem solchen rezept den
thüringen dann möglicherweise auch dass
die cdu bereit wäre sozusagen als eine
art abwehrriegel gegen die afd
die eine linke minderheitsregierung zu
tolerieren
sagen wir sollten das ergebnis heute
abend in ruhe abwarten jetzt ist wie
gesagt hier zeit auch das analysieren
auf der anderen seite wenn das
endergebnis steht muss man klar sagen es
muss eine schnelle regierung gm in
thüringen trotz der möglichkeit dass man
dort als regierungschef auch
weiterarbeiten kann
geschäftsführend und braucht dieses land
eine schnelle und funktionsfähiger
regierung und deswegen kann man jetzt
nicht ewig herum pokern sondern muss zu
einer entscheidung kommen die dazu führt
dass thüringen auch eine stabile
mehrheit bekommt und damit auch im
kontext ostdeutschen länder eine
wichtige rolle weiterspielen kann
wir haben noch viel vor uns auch die
zeiten dass wir letztendlich die
transformation noch nicht geschafft
haben fordern uns heraus dass wir es
gemeinsam schaffen und dazu brauchen wir
eine klare stabile regierung und die
muss jetzt gebildet werden
aber ich glaube dass wir auch
analysieren müssen wie ich welche fehler
haben wir insgesamt gemacht dass diese
mehrheit in der mitte nicht mehr
vorhanden ist aber dann muss ich an der
stelle wirklich noch mal nachfragen wenn
sie von stabiler regierung reden im
moment ist rechnerisch nichts möglich
was meinen sie denn damit
ja das ist das problem dass es
rechnerisch nicht möglich ist es gibt ja
viele möglichkeiten auch nach der
verfassungslage in thüringen wichtig ist
nur eines geschäfts führen kann man nur
einen bestimmten zeitraum tätig sein
man muss gesetze auch verabschieden und
so weiter und so fort und ich hoffe dass
wir mit einem stabilen partner an der
seite da arbeiten können
doch gibt es die möglichkeit auch dort
zu gesprächen zu kommen dass man für die
zukunft die weichen richtig stellt aber
das sollte man anhand des ergebnisses
machen
ich danke jedenfalls mike mohring das in
den letzten monaten so hat mit seinen
leuten gekämpft hat und ich höre daraus
dass die cdu jedenfalls durchaus auch
einen gewissen anspruch ableitet auch in
möglicherweise einer
minderheitskoalition verantwortung zu
übernehmen
ich danke haselhoff nach berlin
herzlichen dank und wir schauen jetzt
mal zur afd die ja kräftig zugelegt hat
ihr ergebnis vom letzten mal verdoppeln
konnte sogar gut verdoppeln können
martin cordes ist bei der afd
das wurde mit jubel aufgenommen
es wurde allerdings wieder aufgenommen
durch die decke fast minute lange hecke
höcker sprechchöre der doppelpartner
ergebnisse von brandenburg und sachsen
und die sorge dass die reizfigur der
stimmen kosten würde es eingetreten
wirklich leichter durch proben genommen
ist schon abgesprochen zu den beim
nächsten mal wird die absolute in demut
mein haupt vor dem thüringer wähler
die thüringer haben heute die wende 2.0
gewählt
[Applaus]
wir haben sich von hass und hetze nicht
beeindrucken lassen
noch niemals in der geschichte der
bundesrepublik ist eine einzelne partei
und eine einzelne person so deformiert
worden wie wir liebe freunde und
trotzdem haben die thüringer dieses
ergebnis möglich gemacht
ein ergebnis das ein klares nein sagt zu
unserer erstarrten parteiendemokratie
ein ergebnis das ja sagt zu einer neuen
lebendigen demokratie und das ist unser
auftrag liebe freunde wir wollen eine
neue vitale demokratie in thüringen und
in deutschland sagt jan hecke der
spitzenkandidat hier in thüringen und in
berlin ist mir jetzt zugeschaltet der
parteivorsitzende der afg gebäuden schon
genannt verschossen und erneuten so also
die afg kräftig zu wenn das gehört dann
auch zur wahrheit doch das ziel stärkste
kraft zu werden jetzt erstmal nicht
erreicht es ist auch nicht ganz so hoch
gegangen wie brandenburg und sachsen
allerdings sind das ist das eine
verdopplung des ergebnisses wie schätzen
sie das ergebnis ein und hatte berneke
jetzt eine stärkung erfahren dadurch und
mit damit auch des rechtsaußen der
rechtsaußen flügel ihrer partei
also ich sehe das ergebnis im
gesamtkontext der drei landtagswahlen
und kann nur sagen ich bin hoch
zufrieden wir haben sie sagt es selbst
jetzt auch in thüringen mehr als eine
verdoppelung wir hatten in brandenburg
eine verdoppelung in sachsen fast eine
verdreifachung der stimmen das heißt das
was wir uns vorgenommen haben zu
erreichen nämlich grandiose erfolge
erfolge bei den landtagswahlen im osten
das haben wir nun wirklich durch und
durch erreicht und sie müssen sie im
gesamtkontext sehen nehmen sie mal die
idee volksparteien die ehemaligen
volksparteien muss man sagen die kommen
insgesamt noch auf 30 prozent cdu 22 spd
acht wir erleben hier ehemalige
volksparteien im niedergang
auf der bürgerlichen seite geht die cdu
immer weiter zurück und wir haben sie
nun hier auch in thüringen überholt
und es ist der aufstieg der afg im
bürgerlichen lager ganz klar und das ist
ein sehr schöner abend für uns wir sind
jeder große wahlsieger mit mehr als elf
prozent zuwachs kann man nichts anderes
feststellen wobei die cdu das sei gesagt
an dieser stelle sie nicht im
bürgerlichen lager sieht und das
bestreitet ich will aber aufnehmen was
sie sagen herr meuten die erfolge von
brandenburg sachsen und jetzt auch
thüringen überall sind ja flügel
vertreter angetreten also die vertreter
eines rechtsaußen kurses wie wird sich
das jetzt für ihre partei dann
weiterentwickeln da ist auf jeden fall
gestärkt
empfehlen sie etwa wären hätte jetzt
auch im bundesvorstand mehr
verantwortung zu übernehmen folgt dass
daraus also zunächst einmal hat mir ein
wirklicher bislang den bundesvorstand
gar nicht angehört und ob er bei der
bundesvorstands wahl ende november
antreten will
das müssen sie befragen und nicht mich
wir sind eine partei die
basisdemokratisch aufgestellt ist und an
jede ist völlig frei darin zu
kandidieren und wenn wir eine hecke das
will dann soll er das sehr gerne tun
das ist nun geschichte die durchaus
folgerichtig wäre so sehe ich das
grundsätzlich ist es so dass die
ostdeutschen landesverbände gestärkt
natürlich in ihrem einfluss aus diesen
wahlen hervorgehen weil wir drei mal
sehr große erfolge hatten
und das ist eine geschichte die wir als
gesamtpartei mit großer befriedigung
erleben dass wir so stark im osten sind
wir müssen diese erfolge jetzt auch im
westen umsetzen dort dauert das etwas
länger aber auch da geht es eindeutig
nach oben
sie sagen sie können sich das durchaus
vorstellen dass wir eine hecke jetzt
auch im bundesvorstand antritt dann
haben sie im vorfeld häufiger darauf
hingewiesen dass sie für sehr
unterschiedliche positionen stehen
anders eben als jörn böcker sie vertritt
dann will ich noch mal fragen diese 23
prozent jetzt das ist das prognose
ergebnis bedeuten die das höcker mit
seinem kurs richtig liegt was die
entwicklung der partei angeht oder sie
ach wissen sie man sollte da nicht äpfel
mit birnen vergleichen also ost und west
ist das schon immer noch ein bisschen
anders ich habe damals in baden
württemberg 2016 auch schon 15 in dem
bundesland mit vollbeschäftigung und
hoher wirtschaftskraft mit der hfg und
meinen freunden erreicht
auch da sind wir sehr sehr stark das
muss man von bundesland zu bundesland
unterschiedlich sehen sie sehen ja zum
beispiel auch wie stark hier die linke
ist die sie sonst nirgendwo so stark
erleben und sie sehen übrigens ein
schöner begleiteffekt der wahl die der
hype um die grünen scheint beendet zu
sein die kommen ja gerade über die
fünf-prozent-hürde
aber das ist sehr voll nein nein nein
überhaupt nicht sondern wir haben hier
als landesverband in thüringen genauso
da waren wir alle beteiligt und böcke
war der spitzenkandidat gemeinsam einen
großen erfolg herum genauso wie das mit
spitzenkandidaten andreas kalbitz in
brandenburg zuvor geschehen ist am
ersten 90 mit den spitzenkandidaten jörg
urban in sachsen und wir haben dreimal
vollen erfolg erzielt das gute zeiten
für die afd
keine frage und ihren schlechte zeiten
für unsere gegner sagten bundessprecher
der afg sie am waldbad wir werden sehen
wohin die reise geht herzlichen dank für
das gespräch und hier im strecke können
war matthias fornoff jetzt noch mal dass
afg ergebnis etwas vertiefen mit
analysedaten absolut das versuchen wir
und schauen auf eine erste aussage die
wir hier in der grafik sehen die afd ist
die einzige partei die die wichtigen
probleme auch beim namen nennt dieser
aussage stimmen er nicht zu 65 prozent
aber bei den fdp anhängern ist es
umgekehrt 93 prozent sagen ja genau so
ist das wie und warum wählt man die afd
sie wird hauptsächlich gewählt wegen
ihrer politischen forderungen sagen alle
19 prozent oder aber um einen denkzettel
für die anderen zu verpassen das sagen
drei viertel der gesamtbetrag tten bei
den fdp wählern sieht das ganz anders
aus fast 70 prozent sagen wegen der
politischen forderungen wählen wir diese
partei nur 29% denkzettel und woher
kommen die wähler der afd
das ist eine ganz interessante grafik
die wir hier sehen
das sehen wir wer heute afd gewählt hat
der hat vor fünf jahren 15 prozent cdu
gewählt das sind ungefähr 40.000 wähler
die die cdu an die afg verloren hat
der größte brocken aber sind ehemalige
nichtwähler 37 prozent oder eben
ungefähr 95 1000 wähler die früher nicht
gewählt haben und jetzt die afd
dankeschön matthias fornoff können wir
jetzt noch mal kurz vertiefen mit
professor karl rudolf korte ja hohes
ergebnis für die fdp nicht ganz so hoch
wie in brandenburg und sachsen auch
gesehen aber kann sich jetzt dieser
rechtsextreme flügel tatsächlich
gestärkt sehen
nein die ergebnisse deuten eher auf
einen stutzen dieses flügels hin
aber in der tat gibt es bei den wählern
auch völlig orientierte ideologische
wähler anders als in anderen
bundesländern auf die wähler sind ihr
protestwähler völkische wähler aber auch
die enttäuschten über die
wiedervereinten also eine klassische
sammlungsbewegung die mit einer
besonderen höcker aus richtung hier am
wahltag aktiv war aber wir sehen vor
allen dingen auch das wieder die
ministerpräsidenten demokratie dominiert
der bonus faktor eines amtierende
ministerpräsident als antipode die fdj
muss bodo ramelow der ministerpräsident
versuchen eine regierung zu bilden
das wird schwierig genug mit der fdp
zusammen könnte es vielleicht gelingen
aber läuft das hier jetzt nicht im
grunde eher auf so eine minderheits
variante heraus die wir auch schon
diskutiert und an den bundespräsidenten
zu erinnern der hatte gesagt bei der
blockierte regierungsbildung im bund
dass der höchster wähler auftrag darin
besteht eine regierungsbildung
herbeizuführen
dann kann also nicht einfach neu wählen
sondern alle sind aufgerufen zu viel zu
sondieren und die linke ist ja hier
nicht wirklich links sondern sie ist
einen auch eine mittepartei so wird sie
wahrgenommen mit einem pragmatisch
präsidentiellen ministerpräsidenten es
ist sehr wahrscheinlich dass es so eine
tolerierung beispielsweise durch die fdp
kommt das gibt auch in anderen
bundesländern der fall
jetzt haben wir eine hochrechnung nicht
gerade wie eine frage habe ich aber noch
die spanier noch auf bitte einmal die
hochrechnung matthias schauen wir uns an
die neuesten zahlen hier ist die
aktuelle hochrechnung von 18 19 demnach
kommt die cdu auf 22 prozent die linke
auf 29,8 die spd auf 8,1 die afg auf
23,2 die grünen 5,5
die fdp 5,4 beide also noch nicht so
ganz sicher drüber und die anderen
zusammen bei sechs prozent
da so viel bewegung drin ist schauen wir
uns jetzt das ganze noch mal an
in gewinnen und verlusten die cdu
verliert minus 11,5 prozentpunkte das
ist ein ziemlicher absturz die linke
legt 1,6 prozentpunkte zu von einem
ohnehin schon guten ergebnis die spd
verliert nach einem schwachen ergebnis
schon vor fünf jahren noch mal 4,3
prozentpunkte
die afg einer der sieger des wahlabends
natürlich mit plus 12,6 punkten
die grünen verlieren leicht die fdp
gewinnt fast 3 prozentpunkte dazu
und jetzt schauen wir mal was das heißt
für die sitzverteilung im erfurter
landtag die absolute mehrheit liegt bei
45 sitzen die cdu kommt auf 21 die linke
auf 28 die spd auf 7
die afg auf 22 die grünen auf 5 und die
fdp ebenfalls auf fünf sitze
was heißt das für die
koalitionsmöglichkeiten hier eine
regierung zu bilden wir sehen die
senkrechte linie das ist die absolute
mehrheit
das derzeit regierende bündnis linke spd
und grüne kommt auf 40 sitze und
verfehlt damit die absolute mehrheit
klar
noch klarer verfehlt ein bündnis aus cdu
spd und grünen diese grenze wenn man die
fdp noch mit ins boot und sind es 38
sitze auch das reicht sicher nicht
ungewöhnliche konstellation
linke spd grüne mit der fdp die kämen
genau auf die 45 sitze die es braucht
haarscharf also wir schauen uns jetzt
aber auch noch mal an was rechnerisch
noch so ginge aber politisch bisher
ausgeschlossen ist
ein bündnis linker und cdu zum beispiel
käme auf 49 sitze und wäre klar drüber
die cdu mit der afc würde es nicht
schaffen mit 43 sitzen und linke und afg
natürlich höchst unwahrscheinlich 50
sitze wäre darüber so viel wird im
moment ja und das passt auch zu meiner
nachfrage die ich stellen wollte wir
sehen professor korte also linke und die
fdp kann man sich jetzt schon irgendwie
gar nicht vorstellbar wenn herr
haselhoff den wir gerade gehört haben
den cdu-ministerpräsident von
sachsen-anhalt jetzt stabile
verhältnisse fordert meint er
möglicherweise da müssen linke und cdu
jetzt zusammen gehen
ja man kann auch ein alt
bundespräsidenten gauck auch hier
bemühen der durchaus angeregt hat linke
und cdu zusammen arbeiten zu lassen
der gestaltungsauftrag geht von bodo
ramelow aus er muss mit allen sprechen
und er wird das ausloten der wird da
nichts ausschließen natürlich ist es
einfacher mit einer mehrheit zu regieren
als sich immer neue partner zu suchen
aber er ist sehr clever mit einer stimme
mehrheit und die parteien haben wir die
fraktionsmitgliedschaft auf gewechselt
über die zeit gut zu regieren
ich kann aber vielleicht wird es dann
noch zu überraschen den bedürfnissen
können auch das ist nicht auszuschließen
danke für den moment jetzt wollen wir zu
den grünen schauen die hatten sich mehr
vorgestellt kurz mal zur alv steht
pansky wieder die etwas mageren gut fünf
prozent aufgenommen wurden ralf anja
siegesmund die spitzenkandidatin hat es
hier sehr schnell auf den punkt gebracht
sie und der andere spitzenkandidat sie
beide sind bitter enttäuscht das hatte
man sich nicht so vorgestellt man musste
es ist ein schweres feld dass es zu
genügen gilt aber dass es so ausgeht und
wenn wir uns jetzt die bilder anschauen
damit hatte man nicht gerechnet
die bundespolitik ist hier sie war auch
in den letzten tagen und wochen hier
stark vertreten man hat wirklich
versucht einen rückenwind aus berlin zu
bekommen mit den themen die im grund für
furore sorgen die den grünen diesen
rückenwind geben aber am ende kam es in
thüringen nicht an rot-rot-grün ist
abgewählt das muss man hier annehmen und
die reaktionen zeigen auch als es darum
ging welches bündnis ist möglich da
waren schon viele sorgenfalten auf den
stirnen zu sehen denn da wird es arbeit
geben überzeugungsarbeit geben ob das
mit den grünen denkbar ist und so reift
die erkenntnis die grünen bäume und
thüringen wachsen nicht in den himmel
aber dass die früchte so klein sind
damit hatte man nicht gerechnet
vielen dank reif schipanski für diese
eindrücke und das können wir jetzt
gleich auch vertiefen denn wir haben ihn
gerade schon gesehen auf der wahlparty
der grünen hier in erfurt ist auch der
bundesvorsitzende robert habeck der mich
jetzt hoffentlich hören kann
gerade das bild schon bemüht die bäume
wachsen nicht in den himmel für die
grünen im osten da sieht man hier einmal
mehr woran liegt das
das stimmt wir haben unser ergebnis von
vor fünf jahren ungefähr gehalten aber
der wahlkampf die motivation war
deutlich höher wir hätten gerne in die
schippe draufgelegt insofern sind wir
damit nicht zufrieden
insgesamt ist es natürlich so dass in
den ostdeutschen bundesländern eine
partei die veränderung will ist schwerer
hat weil die menschen dort in den
letzten 30 jahren veränderungen für drei
biografien gesammelt habe und häufig
genug mit enttäuschungen verbunden in
thüringen speziell war der wahlkampf
noch mal härter als ich ihnen den
sachsen und brandenburg erlebt habe
geradezu unversöhnlicher teilweise und
wir haben eine tonalität des
zusammenführen angelegt und sind damit
kaum durchgekommen und jetzt schwierig
in thüringen habe ich mit der
regierungsbildung minderheitsregierung
wird natürlich jetzt besprochen und
beredet werden sind denn die grünen
dabei wären die mit an ramelow seite
dann stünden sie bereit für ein solches
bündnis welches bündnis erst mal die
frage da muss man glaube ich den
wahlabend abwarten aber wir stehen
thüringen steht vor kompliziertesten
regierungsverhandlungen und gesprächen
bodo ramelow hat den regierungsauftrag
bekommen und wenn wir teil einer
regierung sein sollen er mit uns redet
dann würden wir sicherlich die gespräche
wollen wir haben hier für die
fortsetzung von rot rot grünen geworben
und gestritten
die frage glaube ich richtet sich an
andere parteien insgesamt kann man wohl
festhalten das in einer phase wo sich
die demokratie in deutschland so new
york so sortiert und um formatiert
ausschließeritis nicht weiterhilft und
eigentlich alle demokratischen parteien
miteinander gesprächsfähig sein müssen
diese frage in der tat ist eine die wir
jetzt auch weitergeben werden
herzlichen dank robert habeck der
bundesvorsitzende der grünen war das und
ich bin jetzt auch verbunden mit dem
spd-generalsekretär lars klingbeil der
in berlin auf uns gewartet hat
herzlichen dank herr kleber will aber
zunächst noch mal fragen das sind ja
wirklich auch wiederum schmerzliche
verluste für die spd in thüringen wo sie
jetzt nur noch einstellig sind also
dieser abwärtstrend die wir bei den
letzten wahlen gesehen haben der setzt
sich fort wo liegen ihrer meinung nach
her klingt weil die gründe in thüringen
oder auch stark im bund bitte erlauben
sie mir ganz kurz dass ich herrn ramelow
gratuliere der der eindeutige sieger ist
ja auch den auftrag hat eine regierung
zu bilden ich will auch noch einmal
festhalten dass ich mich darüber freuen
dass die wahlbeteiligung gestiegen ist
das ist ein gutes zeichen für die
demokratie und was das ergebnis der spd
angeht da haben sie recht das ist ein
bitterer enttäuschender haben wir haben
in den letzten wochen erlebt eine
motivierte spd in thüringen die waren
unterwegs wolfgang tiefensee der hohe
beliebtheitswerte hat die
regierungsarbeit ist positiv bewertet
worden aber es hat eben nicht dazu
geführt dass die spd davon profitieren
konnte und das hat wie übrigens in
sachsen und brandenburg auch schon damit
zu tun dass wir gerade in der letzten
phase der wahl eine enorme polarisierung
hatten zwischen dem amtierenden
ministerpräsidenten auf der einen seite
und den rechtsextremen von der afg auf
der anderen seite und die menschen in
thüringen wollten sich entscheiden und
wollten nicht dass die rechtsextremen
vorne liegen davon hat bodo ramelow
profitiert und parteien wie die spd aber
auch die grünen und die fdp konnte nimmt
in dieser polarisierung nichts dazu
gewinnen oder haben sogar verloren
jetzt ist ja noch die frage was leiten
sie aus diesem ergebnis ab dass sie sich
erst mal auch in thüringen neu sortieren
müssen oder bleiben sie fühlen sie sich
fast zur verantwortung weiterhin
verdammt jetzt auch für einen
minderheiten bündnis in irgendeiner form
zur verfügung zu stellen
also das ist ein schwieriges
wahlergebnis weil es glaube ich auch
eine komplizierte situation jetzt in
thüringen bedeutet wir werden jetzt
gespräche führen der auftrag liegt bei 1
ramelow gespräche zu führen ich hoffe
dass alle parteien ausschließen werden
mit der afg zu koalieren oder
irgendwelche art der zusammenarbeit zu
suchen solche absagen erwarte ich auch
für den heutigen abend die müssen klar
und deutlich auch sein und dann müssen
alle demokratischen parteien sich
zusammensetzen und gucken wie man jetzt
künftig in thüringen regieren kann dass
rot-rot-grün vernünftig regiert hat mit
bodo ramelow an der spitze
das sieht man allein an den zahlen die
haben das land vorangebracht
aber wie es jetzt weitergehen kann den
thüringen das muss jetzt ordentlich
beraten werden
aber dafür müssen jetzt auch den
wahlabend abwarten noch sind die
ergebnisse sehr vage und die feinste
sind kompliziert dankeschön lars
klingbeil war das nach berlin und jetzt
können wir das spd-ergebnis matthias
auch nochmal vertiefen ja wir müssen wir
versuchen zu verstehen woran hat es
gelegen dass die parteien noch mal
wieder verliert nach einem ohnehin
schlechten ergebnis vor fünf jahren wir
schauen mal auf die beurteilung von
kandidat und partei ist eine skala von
+5 sehr gut bis -5 da sehen wir wolfgang
tiefensee den spd-spitzenkandidaten mit
einem wert von 1 plus 1,3 das ist ein
ganz guter wird die spd in thüringen
plus 0,6 schon deutlich schlechter
tiefensee hat seiner partei also sicher
nicht geschadet sondern eher genutzt und
die spd im bund wird hier nur mit plus
0,1 bewertet das ist der hinweis wir
haben nämlich weiter gefragt aussagen
zur politik die spd im bund ist schuld
wenn die spd in thüringen schlecht
abschneidet und dem stimmen mehr als
zwei drittel der wählerinnen und wähler
hierzu dankeschön matthias interessante
analyse daten jetzt schauen wir mal zur
fdp die hier in thüringen immer ein
wackelkandidat war sie hat hier geworben
mit dem slogan das zünglein an der waage
zu sein aber es geht jetzt eigentlich
nicht in die richtung die die fdp hier
gemeint hatte sondern sie wird jetzt
möglicherweise vor der frage stehen ob
sie eine rot rot grüne regierung
tolerieren würde das sind schwierige
fragen die jetzt auf die partei zukunft
in der christian ist er heute abend und
das wird leider wahrscheinlich schon
ordentlich diskutiert
ja absolut aber das erste was sie
natürlich am wichtigsten war die
zitterpartie ist vorbei die fdp vorerst
am ziel um 18 uhr
da gab es hier jubel trubel
erleichterung anders lassen sich die
reaktionen nicht zusammenfassen ich habe
sie gerade mit tränen in den augen
gesehen
der thomas kemmerich der landeschef dem
blieb hier bei seinem statement sogar
kurz die luft weg
das hauptziel also der wiedereinzug in
den landtag der ist definitiv mehr
gerückt und dann ist kurz nach 18 uhr
schon thomas kemmerich hier ins mikrofon
getreten und da hören wir jetzt mal kurz
rein
wir sind auf schlagdistanz habt ihr
gesehen dass bei der wahlbeteiligung
haben unser ergebnis verdoppelt in
prozenten und den stimmen wie möglich
gar nicht wissen eine riesenleistung an
alle euch hier im saal an die doch
irgendwo anders stehen an die wähler die
den mut hatten uns zu wählen ob sie uns
obwohl wir lange zeit gar nicht drin
schienen aber jetzt sie zu hause was
knapp schaffen können
ich bin so stolz und froh für euch ihr
habt euch so reingegangen
sagt der spitzenkandidat thomas
kemmerich dem es hier kurz die stimme
verschlagen hat er will kein bündnis mit
der linkspartei eingehen sagt er
jedenfalls wenn die fdp in den landtag
einzieht
darüber wird jetzt die partei natürlich
intensiv diskutieren müssen was das dann
im einzelfall bedeutet ob diese position
gehalten werden kann so jetzt wollen wir
mal schauen wir haben gelernt die
verhältnisse sind kompliziert was
eigentlich die wähler davon halten was
hier gewählt worden ist die
wahlbeteiligung ist gestiegen das ist
erfreulich kassen behrendt ist hier in
erfurt in der landeshauptstadt unterwegs
heute abend und hat einige stimmen
eingefangen
ja wir sind in der wunderschönen
altstadt von erfurt an einem ziemlich
verregneten wahlsonntag und bei mir sind
jetzt drei schwestern sie sind gerade
frisch aus dem kabarett gekommen haben
sie mir gehört aber jetzt haben sie das
wahlergebnis erfahren dass es dann so
ihre spontane reaktion dass der blaue
balken einfach zu hoch ist für die fdp
was sagen sie denn das für möglich eine
koalition von linken spd grünen und der
fdp wäre das in ihrem sinn
ich bin auf alle fälle dafür dass man
sich an einen tisch setzt und gemeinsam
an einem land demokratie arbeitet und
dafür finde ich das natürlich richtig
und aus ihrer sicht was wir so das
wichtigste thema was der neue
landesregierung angehen sollte also auf
alle fälle bildung und die sicherheit
also mehr polizisten mehr sicherheit das
ist glaube ich auch ein ganz großes
problem
vielen dank ja stimmen von drei
wählerinnen aus erfurt hier aus
thüringen und damit zurück zu bettina
schausten ins zdf wahlstudio
herzlichen dank kassen während wir haben
ein wahlsieger des heutigen abends die
linke 30 prozent knapp 30 prozent
möglicherweise 30 war das prognose
ergebnis und das ist ein durchaus
historischer erfolg für die linke die so
hoch in einem land noch nie gelandet ist
das sollten wir uns auch genauer
angucken woher kommen die wähler der
linken matthias woran hat es gelegen und
das schauen wir uns jetzt mal an
in einer ersten grafik die bewertung von
spitzenkandidaten partei so ähnlich wie
wir das gerade bei der spd hatten bodo
ramelow kommt auf einen wert plus 1,6
sehr gut die linke im land auf plus 1,1
doch spürbar schlechter das heißt
ramelow war ein zugpferd für diese
partei die linke im bund mit einer
bewertung von plus 0,3 hier deutlich
schwächer wir haben gefragt hat die
linke in der landesregierung thüringen
vorangebracht und da sehen wir dass 61
prozent aller befragten nicht etwa der
linken anhänger sondern aller befragten
sagen ja das stimmt und das ist
natürlich schon ein wert den man vor
fünf jahren sicher nicht erwartet hätte
dankeschön matthias und das können wir
noch einmal vertiefen mit der
bundesvorsitzenden der linken katja
kipping die hier bei der wahlparty auch
in erfurt ist und nach der enttäuschung
von brandenburg und sachsen sieht man
ihnen an dass über dieses ergebnis
natürlich die freude groß ist aber ich
muss sie sofort fragen was macht die
linke was macht bodo ramelow jetzt da
raus
heute haben freuen wir uns natürlich
zuallererst weil die linke hat hier in
thüringen zusammen mit bodo ramelow
gezeigt die linke kann stärkste partei
sie kann regieren aus der regierung
heraus sogar noch zulegen und sie kann
ministerpräsident das ist natürlich ein
tolles signal
das ergebnis ist ein klarer
regierungsauftrag
und wie es jetzt weitergehen wissen ich
glaube jetzt ist noch nicht der
zeitpunkt wo wir total spekulieren weil
es kann sich noch viel verschieben bis
das endergebnis kommt auch über die
direktwahlkreise insofern wir haben
immer gesagt wir kämpfen bis zuletzt für
eine fortführung von rot rot grün mit
dem mp bodo ramelow und das tun wir so
lange bis das amtliche endergebnis
kollegen ja das ist in der tat so dass
wir davon noch entfernt sind aber
rot-rot-grün ist von einer mehrheit
allerdings doch sehr sehr weit entfernt
deshalb muss man natürlich auch jetzt
schon fragen was ist die alternative
ganz grundsätzlich will ich mal gefallen
kann sich denn die linke möglicherweise
wenn sie jetzt auch die regiert den
regierungsauftrag beanspruchen
vorstellen mit der cdu zu sprechen
zumindestens und zusammenzugehen
also jetzt um diese uhrzeit ist wirklich
noch nicht der moment wo wir anfangen
alle möglichen varianten durchzuspielen
und zu spekulieren kann nur sagen ein
sache steht auf jeden fall fest wurde
ramelow die linke thüringen wird
einladen wird eine regierungsbildung in
angriff nehmen und sie tut das auch mit
blick auf die situation in thüringen
weil wir wollen in thüringen dass sich
die situation in den schulen weiter
verbessert wir wollen dass ein weiteres
gebührenfreies kindergartenjahr geht es
und wir wollen auch weiterhin
beschäftigte bei ihren kämpfen um höhere
löhne unterstützen
dazu brauchen wir eine regierung unter
der führung von bodo ramelow sagt katja
kipping die linke will heute abend wie
man eindeutig hören kann doch vor allem
feiern herzlichen dank dass sie dennoch
sich bemüht haben
gegen den vater schon in villarreal
genau also dankeschön frauen hierfür
wahlparty in erfurt jetzt haben wir
schon vorhin gehört das ist für die spd
ein eher enttäuschendes ergebnis und wir
können jetzt mal die kommissarische
spd-bundesvorsitzende malu dreyer hören
die in berlin vor die presse gegangen
ist sie können sich vorstellen dass die
sozialdemokraten enttäuscht über das
ergebnis vom heutigen abend wir hatten
bis zuletzt noch gehofft und auch sehr
stark gekämpft den thüringen dafür dass
wir besser abschneiden und deshalb will
ich selbstverständlich an dieser stelle
wolfgang tiefensee und den helfern
helferinnen sozialdemokraten sehr sehr
herzlich danken
ich weiß sie haben alles gegeben sie
sind auch sehr gute minister ministerin
in der regierung die zufriedenheit mit
der regierungsarbeit war in thüringen
sehr sehr hoch und nicht desto trotz
konnte die spd dort leider nicht
profitieren
ich gratuliere natürlich bodo ramelow
dem ministerpräsidenten kollegen sehr
sehr herzlich und bei dieser wahl hat
sich eben wieder einmal mehr gezeigt
ähnlich wie in brandenburg und in
sachsen dass es gerade in den letzten
tagen und wochen zu einer starken
polarisierung gekommen ist zwischen dem
regierungs dem ministerpräsidenten in
dem fall und der afd
ich gehe davon aus dass sich viele
wähler und wählerinnen das zeigen ja
auch alle umfragen die man sehen konnte
und kann dass sie sich
für die regierung entschieden haben
gegen die afg und damit auch ein
deutliches votum ausgesprochen haben
trotzdem schockiert es mich natürlich
total oder sehr das ergebnis der afd
denn es sind über 20 prozent der bürger
und bürgerinnen die afg gewählt haben
und das bei einer thüringischen
thüringischen raf de mit höcker an der
spitze der vom verfassungsschutz
überwacht wird und der rechtsextremist
das ist eine schockierende situationen
die spd wird sich natürlich damit auch
niemals abfinden sondern immer dagegen
angehen und dagegen kämpfen denn das
gesellschaftsbild afd entspricht in
keinster weise dem unseren und es ist
immer unser auftrag als aufrechte
demokraten demokratien dagegen anzugehen
und das ist im übrigen auch die aufgabe
aller demokraten
da in den vorläufigen ergebnissen jetzt
noch viel bewegung ist stellen wir uns
auch auf einen längeren abend ein
es ist ja ganz offensichtlich so dass im
moment die lage so ist dass es für die
fortsetzung der rot rot grünen regierung
als mehrheits regierung im moment keine
grundlage vorhanden ist auch das ist
sehr bedauerlich aber nichtsdestotrotz
haben ist wahrscheinlich noch lang und
wir werden das verfolgen abend und
komplizierte verhältnisse das war die
kommissarische spd-bundesvorsitzende
malu dreyer und jetzt kommen wir zur cdu
die hier in thüringen mit gut 22 prozent
im moment doch deutliche zweistellige
verluste eingefahren hat und damit auch
den spitzenplatz 1 bösz den sie ja beim
letzten mal noch hatte wenn sie dann
auch keine regierung bilden konnte
es ist die rede von stabilen
verhältnissen da müsste dann die cdu
eigentlich eine rolle spielen wir hören
jetzt erstmal hier den spitzenkandidaten
landesvorsitzenden mike mohring
so schön das
ihr da seid für thüringen ist das für
die demokratische mitte heute ein
bitteres ergebnis wir haben für diese
demokratische mitte gekämpft und diese
demokratische mitte hat keine mehrheit
bekommen
das stimmt und nachdenklich wichtig ist
natürlich rot rot grün hat heute keine
mehrheit bekommen die regierung haben
wir durch abgewählt auch das ergebnis
trage
[Musik]
aber ich wiederhole das noch mal dass
sie demokratische mitte keine mehrheit
bekommen hat das ist das bittere
ergebnis dieses wahlabends und deswegen
entsteht daraus auch eine verantwortung
für uns in der feststellung zunächst das
modul ramelow vor allen dingen gewonnen
hat weil er von linken wenn spd und
grüne stimmen gezogen hat und dass die
beiden heute auch so mit uns gemeinsamen
demokratischen mittel so schwach
abgeschlossen haben ist auch ein
ergebnis dieses zug ist auf der einen
seite es gibt keine linke mehrheit in
diesem land wo das ist ein zustand mit
denen wir nicht gerechnet haben
mit dem glaube ich niemand gerechnet hat
seit 1949 nicht gab es demokratische
wahlen dieses jahr im ergebnis geführt
haben die eine regierungsbildung und
damit nicht ermöglichen dennoch dass die
thüringen und thüringen heute so stark
werden gegangen sind ist ein
ermutigendes zeichen
und es ist wichtig bin froh dass 30
jahre nach der friedlichen revolution so
viele thüringer bürgerinnen und bürger
von ihrem wahlrecht gebraucht gemacht
haben und deswegen muss man das
wahlergebnis akzeptieren und jetzt auch
schauen was man gemeinsam mit diesem
wahlergebnis macht da war noch nie
jemand mit so einem ergebnis gerechnet
hat kann man auch nicht sagen ja was
macht man mit diesem ergebnis
micron zu seinem cdu-ergebnis und auch
das können wir jetzt vertiefen die cdu
war ja immer stärkste partei in
thüringen bis jetzt sind wir schon mal
ein paar gründe an warum das vielleicht
diesmal nicht mehr so wahr wir sehen
hier die bewertung der spitzenkandidaten
und der partei mike mohring den wir
gerade gehört haben
er schneidet ab mit plus 0,9 genauso wie
die cdu hier im land also er hat nicht
wirklich zusätzlich was gebracht wenn
man dagegen vergleich sehen bodo ramelow
für die linke plus 1,6 viel stärker als
seine partei
das macht natürlich auch ein stück der
amtsbonus wir haben eine politische
aussage zur abstimmung gestellt ohne die
cdu in der landesregierung kann türen
wirtschaftlich erfolgreich sein
dem stimmen zwei drittel gut zwei
drittel zu und das ist brandgefährlich
für die cdu die natürlich ihre
kernkompetenz im bereich wirtschaft
arbeitsplätze hat uns zuletzt eine
dritte grafik wer hat die cdu gewählt
die forschungsgruppe wahlen hat 17.000
interviews an die
wahllokalen geführt und da sehen wir
quer durch die altersgruppen verluste
für die cdu
besonders heftig bei den unter
30-jährigen auf das gesamtergebnis da
ganz schwach aber wir sehen auch hier
bei den über 60-jährigen wo die cdu
normalerweise richtig punktet ein
mittelmäßiges ergebnis da hat sich viel
verloren an die linke dankeschön
matthias und in berlin begrüße ich jetzt
den cdu-generalsekretär paulsberg
schönen amt hat sie mehr
guten abend die die cdu hat alle ihre
ziele verfehlt nicht mehr stärkste kraft
sozusagen das was sie als irrtum mal
bezeichnete haben dass es hier in
thüringen eine linke regierung gab
sollte geändert werden das klappt nicht
was machen sie jetzt aus diesem ergebnis
welche konsequenzen ziehen sie daraus
das ist ein bitterer am nicht nur für
die union sondern vor allem auch für die
demokratische mitte in thüringen die
demokratische mitte hat keine
regierungsoption aber ich sage ihnen
ganz deutlich auch heute abend wir
bleiben bei dem was wir auf dem
bundesparteitag beschlossen haben was
mike mohring auch selbst immer wieder
gesagt hat es wird mit der union keine
koalition mit den linken und auch nicht
mit der fdp geben wenn mit beidem nicht
dann geben sie aber damit jetzt auch den
anspruch auf eine regierungsbildung ab
denn mit dem sollten sie dann regieren
aber zunächst geht es ums land und dann
um die partei es kann ja nicht sein dass
wir inhaltlich unüberbrückbare
differenzen zurück stellen nur um eine
an einer regierung beteiligt zu sein
wir sind uns als cdu und auch die cdu
thüringen ist sich ihrer verantwortung
bewusst es gibt eine verfassung und dort
gibt es regeln zunächst einmal bleibt
diese regierung geschäftsführend im amt
und wir stehen bereit alles zu tun was
dem land thüringen benutzt aber wir
stehen auch zu unserem wahlversprechen
keine koalition mit linken oder afd man
hat der frühere bundespräsident gauck
die cdu durchaus aufgerufen was die ein
bündnis mit linken angeht das noch mal
zu überdenken ob man da wirklich bei dem
ausschließen bleiben will
sie schließen heute abend nicht nur ein
bündnis sondern auch eine tolerierung
es gibt ganz unterschiedliche
konstellationen aber wir sagen ganz klar
koalition und jede ähnliche form die
dementsprechend würde schließen wir aus
ich sage es ihnen ganz offen mit einer
partei die bis heute nicht in der lage
ist die ddr zu bezeichnen und als das
was sie war nämlich eine unrechtsstaat
wie soll da eine zusammenarbeit mit der
cdu funktioniere gut was schwebt ihnen
dann für ein bündnis vor hätte sie mehr
zunächst einmal gibt es eine verfassung
die ersetzt eine rechtslage eben voraus
dass diese geschäfts dieser regierung
geschäftsführend im amt bleibt und alles
weitere muss man jetzt in den nächsten
tagen beraten wir werden das auch morgen
im präsidium und der bundesvorstand tun
wir warten jetzt zunächst einmal auf das
endgültige amtliche endergebnis und dann
wird man in anbetracht der
verfassungslage die dinge bewerten
bewerten müssen aber noch mal
man kann nicht seine grundsätze über
bord werfen nur um an einer regierung
beteiligt zu sein sagte der
cdu-generalsekretär polzin jahr
herzlichen dank nach berlin und jetzt
haben wir eine weitere
gesprächspartnerin hier im studio katrin
göring-eckardt die die
bundestagsfraktion in berlin führt aber
heute als thüringerin in thüringen ist
vor gericht wir wollen uns kurz
gemeinsam ein paar analysedaten zu ihrer
partei an alltags befragung einige daten
gerade auch nach alter für die grünen
das sehen wir hier wer hat die grünen
gewählt hier in thüringen da sehen wir
bei den unter 30-jährigen 11 prozent ist
ein guter wert plus 3 punkte
und dann nimmt es ab nur 7 prozent 6
prozent bei den 30 bis 60 jährigen und
nur drei prozent bei den über 60
jährigen
zusätzlich kommt als problem für die
grünen dazu dass in dieser erfolgreichen
gruppe unter 30 die anzahl der
wählerinnen und wähler deutlich geringer
ist und das thema klimawandel ist da
natürlich eins in dieser altersgruppe
was besonders virulent ist wir haben
gefragt in thüringen gibt es viel
wichtigere themen als den klimawandel
und dem stimmen hier fast drei viertel
der wählerinnen und wähler zu das ist
ein sehr hoher wert und natürlich ist
das für eine partei die sich das zum
zentralen politik aspekt gewählt hat ein
ganz schwieriger wird
vermögen erklärt ihr kernthema hat nicht
gezogen hatten sie es trotzdem besser
erwartet wir werden jedenfalls besser
erhofft das ist ja klar an so einem
abend nach einem sehr harten auch sehr
polarisierten wahlkampf aber dem ist
natürlich auch und polarisierung beim
klimaschutz gar beim thema windkraft und
anderen dingen das muss man ganz offen
sagen wir hatten uns da mehr erhofft wie
sehen sie ihre rolle jetzt mit mal
gerade gut fünf prozent bei diesem
komplizierten verhältnissen da muss es
ja jetzt lösungen geben wofür stünden
sie bereit
erstmal ist das ja jetzt die schwere
aufgabe für bodo ramelow team ich von
hier aus auch noch mal sehr hat sich
gratuliere dafür zu sorgen dass ist eine
handlungsfähige regierung gibt wir haben
vorher gesagt das wollen wir so und wir
bleiben auch dabei wenn er auf uns
zukommen dann führen wir natürlich
gespräche aber wir sind da jetzt nicht
diejenigen die das spiel spielen sondern
das muss er machen er ist da im lied und
für uns heißt es als partei aber dass
wir selbstverständlich gerade im
ländlichen raum die frage des
klimaschutzes was bedeutet das für die
leute was haben sie auch davon was gibt
es an verbesserungen sehr sehr viel mehr
besprechen müssen auch in der
konfrontation und auseinandersetzung nun
kommen sie aus berlin ihr arbeitsplatz
ist berlin
welche folgen welche konsequenzen sehen
sie auch für berlin
ja genau das also ich glaube das was uns
nicht gelungen ist es wirklich in der
breite der gesellschaft in stadt und
land mit diesem thema anzukommen es auch
nicht das einzige was wir haben weil wir
ja gerade in den letzten monaten immer
darauf beharrt haben dass soziales und
klimaschutz zusammen gehört nur dann
kann man diese transformation
erfolgreich machen die wir so dringend
brauchen weil wir nicht mehr so viel
zeit haben wenn man sich anschaut wie
schnell die erderwärmung vor anzieht
aber sie sind angesichts der ergebnisse
durchaus gewarnt was auch gewisse
höhenflüge der grünen angeht das muss
man ganz klar sagen wir haben immer
gesagt das ist im osten schwieriger das
haben wir schon in brandenburg gemerkt
das haben wir auch in sachsen gemerkt
wir haben auch gemerkt dass es ein
effekt gibt in den letzten wochen in
richtung des ministerpräsidenten der
regiert das haben wir erlebt und wir
haben diese hatte auseinandersetzung mit
der afg das muss man auch noch sagen was
die aufgabe eben auch es ist hier für
die demokratie zu kämpfen
30 jahre nach der friedlichen revolution
mit jemanden der an der spitze seiner
partei zu recht falsch ist genannt
werden muss sagt katrin göring eckardt
die fraktionsvorsitzende der grünen im
bundestag danke fürs kommen
ins studio so und jetzt können wir mal
zur fdp schauen tun dass sofort nach
einer nächsten hochrechnung das muss
immer vorrang auf die wir besonders
gespannt sind und hier sind die zahlen
die hochrechnung um 1849 die cdu 22,2
prozent große verluste die linke knapp
30% 29,6 dazu gewinne die spd 8,3
prozent mit verlusten die afg 23,6
prozent mit deutlichen gewinnen
die grünen bei 5,4 prozent und leichten
verlusten die fdp bei 5,2 prozent
und da zu gewinnen allerdings sehen wir
beide mit 5,4 und 5,2 noch nicht allzu
weit weg von dieser fünf-prozent-hürde
den man erst mal nehmen muss wir schauen
mal auf die sitzverteilung im erfurter
landtag 45 sitze braucht man für die
mehrheit cdu 21 linke 27 spd 8 hfg 22
grüne 5 und fdp 5 die reihenfolge
übrigens die wir jetzt zeigen hängt ab
von der platzierung der parteien bei den
letzten landtagswahlen und jetzt schauen
wir auf die möglichen koalitionen für
wen reicht das ist die linie die man
überschreiten oder mindestens erreichen
muss 45 sitze die jetzige regierung
linke spd und grüne mit 40 sitzen
verfehlt das deutlich noch deutlicher
eine regierung aus cdu spd und grünen
selbst wenn die fdp mit dabei wäre würde
es nur für 39 stimmen reichen also zu
wenig ein ungewöhnliches bündnis bisher
aus linken spd grünen und fdp das käme
genau auf die 45 sitze die man hier
braucht und jetzt schauen wir uns aber
auch noch an rechnerisch was möglich
wäre wenn nicht alles möglichen schon
ausgeschlossen worden wäre politisch zum
beispiel ein bündnis von linken und cdu
käme auf 48 sitze das reichte deutlich
ein bündnis von cdu und fdp ebenfalls
ausgeschlossen würde es auch nicht
schaffen derzeit linke und afg höchst
unwahrscheinlich käme ebenfalls auf 49
und würde es schaffen
dankeschön matthias fornoff für und in
berlin ist mir jetzt der
bundesvorsitzende der fdp zugeschaltet
und herr lindner
hallo guten abend frau schausten 100 sie
haben gerade vielleicht unsere
hochrechnung hören können danach ist die
fdp bei 5,2 prozent das ist noch nicht
ganz das sichere terra aber wir gehen
mal davon aus dass sie es tatsächlich
wieder in den thüringer landtag
geschafft hatten erhalten das wäre für
sie ein erfolg sie haben sich angeboten
hier in thüringen als zünglein an der
waage
und das muss ihre partei jetzt nun auch
aus einlösen tut sie es auch wenn die
linke fragt ob die liberalen bereit sind
zur tolerierung die fdp hat ihre stimmen
ja mehr als verdoppelt gegenüber dem
letzten mal im team wahlbeteiligung
effekt wird man das sehr deutlich sehen
und wir haben diese stimmen erhalten für
eine klare mission nämlich eine andere
wirtschaftspolitik zu machen die
bildungspolitik wieder gutzumachen gegen
einen klima absolutismus für mehr
vernunft und das ist unter führung der
linkspartei mit grünen und spd im boot
nicht realisierbar unsere perspektive
war eine andere regierung und nicht die
fortsetzung dessen was in den
vergangenen jahren thüringen nicht nach
vorne gebracht hat
nun reicht es aber nicht für das
avisierte vierer bündnis mit cdu spd
grünen und fdp das heißt die liberalen
nehmen sich ins raus aus allem anderen
nein wir sind ja in der sache immer
gesprächsbereit wer weiß was in den
nächsten tagen kommt wir sehen dass der
regierungsbildungsauftrag aber an der
fdp und knapp vorbei gegangen ist
sondern der ist bei anderen parteien
insbesondere bei der linken die werden
jetzt gespräche führen für uns ist klar
mit zusammenarbeit mit der linkspartei
ich meine es eine partei die den
sozialismus in deutschland einführen
will
mieten deckel hier in berlin eingriff
ins eigentum und so weiter und so fort
also es kann keine ernsthafte frage sind
wir da in eine koalition eintreten aber
vielleicht gibt es andere
konstellationen die sachbezogene
zusammenarbeit möglich machen ich denke
an eine minderheitsregierung all das
wissen wir nicht das wird in den
nächsten tag
entschieden für uns wichtig ist nach
zehn jahren haben wir es jetzt
möglicherweise heute abend geschafft
wieder in einem ostdeutschen landtag in
ganz anderen wettbewerbsumfeld und das
bestätigt unseren kurs den wir in der
bundes partei eingeschlagen haben der
länder gilt für sie der satz den man
jetzt viel höher demokraten müssen
zusammenhalten und zählt die linke für
sie dazu demokraten müssen
zusammenhalten aber dann sage ich an
diesem abend mal ein hartes wort wenn
sie mich dazu einladen
die linkspartei hat in ihrem
grundsatzprogramm stehen dass sie in
deutschland den sozialismus einführen
will
die will nicht eine andere
regierungspolitik die will eine andere
wirtschaft und gesellschaftsordnung und
auf der anderen seite die afg will dass
auch die wollen eine völkische politik
machen und deshalb ist eine
zusammenarbeit will die nicht zu tal
gleichsetzen diese beiden parteien aber
ist eine regierungszusammenarbeit mit
linke und afd
für die fdp ausgeschlossen da ist
christian lindner klar der
bundesvorsitzende der fdp herzlichen
dank nach berlin so und hier im studio
begrüße ich carsten schneider ist
parlamentarischer geschäftsführer der
spd-bundestagsfraktion und seinerseits
thüringer und hat hier jetzt heute mit
einem wirklich bitteren spd-ergebnis zu
kämpfen
vielleicht erstmal die frage wie tief
geht ja die enttäuschung sie haben
drittel ihrer wähler verloren
ja das ist für uns ein ganz bitterer tag
schwer enttäuschend weil wir glaube ich
jetzt fünf jahre hier in thüringen auch
mit unseren ministerin landtag eine gute
arbeit gemacht haben das hat sich nicht
ausgezahlt
im endeffekt wählerwanderung noch sehen
das habe ich getan noch nicht aber geht
wahrscheinlich in richtung bodo ramelow
dh der effekt dass der mp das quasi
alles abzieht
wie es beim brandenburger in sachsen
auch gewesen ist sie eingetreten und
warten darauf dass sie mal ein bier
trinken kann
noch ist es nicht soweit sie müssen
nämlich noch die frage beantworten wie
sich die spd jetzt positioniert in
dieser wirklich komplizierten
gemengelage nehmen sie sich jetzt
erstmal raus und warten ab wer sie fragt
sie stehen sie auch für möglicherweise
eine minderheits modell unter
cdu-führung zur verfügung
also heute ist ein tag
für uns wo man erstmal durchschnaufen
das ergebnis mitnehmen
das ist wirklich bitter nach ihnen auch
ganz offen die das ergebnis für die afd
bei so einer rechtsextremen führung das
ist für mich als thüringer das ist schon
sehr enttäuschend und machte noch angst
und deswegen glaube ich das sehr gut
obwohl darauf ankommt dass
runterzuschlucken mund abputzen ja und
dann war da machen dass wir hier in
thüringen eine stabile regierung in
bekommen oder dann übergangsregierung
dieses land stabil halten und dann auch
wieder vertrauen zurückgewinnen es
bringt nichts da jetzt in den sand zu
schmeißen aber ist natürlich ein
rückschlag einsatz noch zur auswirkung
auf den bund sie sind bundespolitiker
die groko hat hier wirklich einen
starken dämpfer einfahren müssen wie
lange kann die noch bestehen
ja je mehr man darüber spekuliert doch
mal zu sagt das ist alles so schlecht
ist er wird nicht besser um öffentlichen
bild glaube es gibt denn riesen
unterschied zwischen dem was wir
tatsächlich geleistet haben und auch ein
gesetz beschlossen haben und dem
öffentlichen bild und deswegen sage ich
wir werden jetzt eine kurze harte
debatte innerhalb der spd eine
entscheidung treffen die getan
dankeschön carsten schneider für den
besuch hier im studio und kurz vor 19
uhr sammeln sich jetzt hier auch schon
die ersten spitzenkandidaten die
pünktlich zur 19 uhr sendung dazu kommen
und ich begrüße als erster dem
ministerpräsidenten bodo ramelow der
auch der wahlsieger des heutigen abends
ist mit knapp 30 prozent
das hätte ihn vor einiger zeit sicher
noch keiner zugetraut gleichwohl ramelow
fühlen sie sich heute irgendwie
gleichzeitig als sieger und auch als
verlierer überhaupt nicht thüringen ist
der gewinner
wir haben eine stark zugenommene
wahlbeteiligung ich finde dass ein
ausgesprochen gutes zeichen für eine
parlamentarische demokratie
nachdem wir jahre erlebt haben wo es
immer weniger und immer weniger geworden
ist und in der tat was ich bedauerlich
finde ist dass die gute arbeit der
landesregierung die von drei parteien
getragen worden ist dass diese guten
ergebnisse nicht gleichermaßen in
wahlergebnisse nieder sich
niedergeschlagen haben denn die spd
genauso wie die bündnis 90 die grünen
haben in der
arbeit der regierung eine genau solche
kraft entwickelt dass wir als rot rot
grüne landesregierung hervorragende
umfrageergebnisse hatte und die bürger
einfach gesagt haben in ostdeutschland
ist dass die beliebteste landesregierung
und deswegen sage ich das ist ein
bisschen heute ab was mich traurig macht
das die beiden anderen partner nicht so
zulegen konnten wie ich es mir gewünscht
hätte
nun müssen sie sich möglicherweise
schütteln und nach ganz neuen partnern
suchen wie weit geht da ihre bereit sind
erstmal ist es so dass das thüringer
landesparlament in der lage ist mit den
demokratischen kräften immer wieder zu
neuen lösungen zu kommen
das heißt wir haben auch gelegenheit
jetzt über die eine oder andere frage
mal zu reden wie direktdemokratische
elemente auch der vorschlag den herr
mohring mal gemacht hatte zum
fakultativen referendum
wie solche themen mit eingebaut werden
können damit wir den bürgern das gefühl
geben dass es nicht nur darum geht alle
fünf jahre ein kreuzchen zu machen
sondern tatsächlich dass wir mit den
bürgern in diesem land auch die
parlamentarische demokratie näher
zusammenrücken
aber nun haben wir heute abend die
stimmen schon gehört dass die cdu und
gerade auch die fdp dieses zusammengehen
mit der linken ausschließt haben sie
etwas im köcher wie sie auch andere
überzeugen können ist doch vielleicht zu
versuchen die direkte demokratie also
auch volksabstimmungen und partizipative
elemente sind dinge die wir im parlament
beschließen können und dann wird nicht
nach parteipolitische präferenz
abgestimmt sondern auch inhalt und ich
hoffe darauf dass wir solche öffnen
öffnungen auch hinbekommen dass man
miteinander auch arbeiten kann
aber der anspruch die regierung zu
bilden ist ganz klar da also das ist
doch nun eindeutig einerseits bei den
beliebtheitswerten und andererseits dass
wir einen so kräftigen auftrag bekommen
haben dass meine partei auch noch mal
zugelegt hat ist doch ein deutlicher
ausdruck dafür dass die wählerinnen und
wähler erwarten dass von mir die
regierungsbildung vorangetrieben wird
und deswegen bin ich ein bisschen
verwundert dass die union die eine große
wahlniederlage gerade verkraften muss
dass diese union sich jetzt hinstellt
und den wählern gegenüber sagt das sei
keine demokratische mitte also die mitte
dieses landes ist das land als solches
und nicht eine einzelne partei
bodo ramelow der ministerpräsident der
linken der das auch wieder werden will
und bleiben will und wir gehen jetzt
direkt natürlich ab zu unseren heute
-nachrichten nach mainz und melden uns
hier in der runde der spitzenkandidaten
dann gleich wieder